[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren so führte nach acht heute
präsentieren wir ihnen wie gewohnt fünf
köpfe fünf meinungen es gibt keine show
effekte dafür ein feuerwerk der wörter
heute gäste unsere gäste heute abend die
linken politikerin sahra wagenknecht
stellvertretende vorsitzende
fdp-fraktion im bundestag konstantin
coole bild chefredakteur und tv chef
claus strunz und last but not least der
leiter der bild parlamentsredaktion reis
schule wir wollen heute direkt mit frau
wagenknecht beginnen und dem thema was
sie für heute mitgebracht hat
ja also ich möchte wirklich über die
frage reden was machen wir in
deutschland und was machen wir falsch
meiner während in vielen anderen
europäischen ländern offen ein anderes
virus kursiert weil dort mit blick auf
oregon mittlerweile die pandemie für
beendet erklärt wurde nahezu alle
maßnahmen aufgehoben wurden oder
zumindest beschlüsse gefasst worden
lockern wir im schneckentempo und
natürlich wird gesagt ja bis 20 märz
sind die maßnahmen weg aber für junge
leute ist es halt bitter wenn sie nach
wie vor zum beispiel wenn sie nicht
geimpften nicht in clubs und diskotheken
dürfen es ist für familien ein problem
dass sie nach wie vor in der situation
sind bei hochzeiten beerdigungen ihre
nicht geimpften verwandten und bekannten
aus laden zu müssen und die frage ist ja
wozu das alles und ich höre dann über
herrn scholz oder auch ein lauterbach
wie sagen ja das alles hat uns sozusagen
hat dazu geführt dass wir sehr gut durch
die pandemie gekommen sind dass wir
besser sind als andere länder ich habe
mir vor kurzem mal angeguckt die zahlen
wie viele menschen an und mit corona
gestorben sind in den letzten drei
monaten und aber ich echt verblüfft weil
es ist tatsächlich so deutschland hat
die restriktivsten maßnahmen trotzdem
sind bei uns relativ viele menschen
gestorben übrigens sogar mehr als in
großbritannien wo die impfquote eher
niedriger ist als bei uns wo gar keine
maßnahmen mehr waren und natürlich auch
mehr als in den meisten anderen ländern
und wenn ich dann immer höre ja das
liegt an der großen brücke muss man auch
sagen es gibt kaum ein land in europa
dass in einem solchen daten blindflug
durch die ganze pandemie rauscht wir
wissen ja noch nicht mal genau wie viele
menschen geimpft sind das lka sagt
wahrscheinlich fünf prozent mehr als im
dschungel gemeldet wurden bei den
variablen bei den älteren wären das dann
93 wir wissen natürlich in deutschland
auch nicht wie viele chinesen sind weil
wir das auch nicht messen wir wissen bis
heute nicht wie viele wirklich weg in
corona in den krankenhäusern liegen
trotzdem wird das alles als argument
benutzt eben einschränkungen aufrecht zu
erhalten und eine einschränkung eine
ganz gravierende die soll sogar über den
zwanzigster märz hinaus aufrechterhalten
bleiben und das ist die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht und da muss ich
ehrlich sagen das finde ich wirklich
empörend wie man hier mit pflegerinnen
und pflegern umgeht und ihnen den stuhl
quasi vor die tür stellen will menschen
die sich jetzt zwei jahre um andere
gekümmert haben die menschen gepflegt
haben auch als es noch gar keine impfung
gehabt die wahrscheinlich auch alle
vermutlich die infektion schon hinter
sich haben und das einzige argument was
da immer angeführt wird und das ist ja
das womit auch das gesetz begründet
wurde ja wir müssen die bullen arabien
schützen aber alle seriösen virologen
herrscht reger stört alle anderen sagen
die impfung schützt gar nicht davor dass
ich mich infiziere und andere anstecken
und wir sehen das ja auch wir haben ja
teilweise in den ländern mit den
höchsten impfquoten die höchsten
instanzen aber wenn die impfung gar
nicht davor schützt dass sich andere
anstecken kann dann muss ich sagen ist
doch diese einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht für pflegerinnen und pfleger
eine ganz absurde maßnahme die nur den
pflegenotstand verstärkt die den auch
wenn sie jetzt nicht direkt umgesetzt
wird das weiß man ja noch nicht genau
die den pflegerinnen und pflegern ein
damoklesschwert über den kopf hängt und
die natürlich junge leute vielleicht
auch davon abhält noch mehr abhält sich
für diesen beruf ausbilden zu lassen ich
finde das ist der völlig falsche weg und
ich finde man muss dringend darüber
nachdenken solche unsinnigen gesetze
zurück zu nehmen und auf keinen fall auf
diesem weg weiter zu gehen also über
frau wagenknecht erstmal ist ja eines
völlig klar ist ist eine gute situation
mit blick auf die zahlen wir laufen auf
ein datum zu nämlich den zwanzigster
märz wo ganz wesentliche maßnahmen
aufgehoben werden und das ist genau der
richtige weg denn wir haben so viele
freiheits einschränkungen gehabt in der
pandemie dass die menschen oft man jetzt
mehr unter diesen freiheitseinschränkung
gelitten haben als unter einer konkreten
infektion ich erinnere an die situation
in den familien die situation der kinder
an häusliche gewalt die verwahrlosung
der innenstädte all das große probleme
wir brauchten scharfe maßnahmen aber
jetzt ist auch der richtige moment
gekommen um sie aufzuheben aber mit
blick auf die einrichtungs bezogen
impfpflicht und der blick auf die frage
reicht die impfquote aus um auch im
nächsten herbst auch im nächsten winter
freiheitseinschränkung mich haben zu
können da muss man ganz klar sagen wäre
es gut gewesen wenn nicht sie unter
anderem auch so große zweifel gestreut
hätten an der impfung hätten sich
vielleicht auch mehr pflegerinnen und
pfleger impfen lassen und wir hätten
jetzt nicht so eine situation also ein
bisschen mehr werbung für die impfung
bisschen mehr übersicht und vertrauen in
diese wirksam das
ehrlich gesagt also dass ich zweifel an
der impfung gesät habe ich habe immer
dafür geworben dass sich ältere menschen
impfen lassen aber erst pflegerinnen und
pfleger die in medizinischen berufen
arbeiten sich aus ihrem urteil davon
abhängig machen ob ich mich impfen lasse
oder was ich öffentlich sage das halte
ich für ein bisschen absurd ich bekomme
ja auch ganz viel resonanz von menschen
die sich gegen die impfung entscheiden
und da gibt es meistens sehr plausible
gründe das sind zum beispiel menschen
die haben die erstimpfung nicht
vertragen und die sagen da möchte ich
keine zweite oder es sind menschen die
im unmittelbaren umkreis oder auch in
den pflegeheimen gesehen haben dass
menschen doch auch durch die impfung zu
schaden kommen können was es ja auch
gibt das wird ja gar nicht bestritten
oder es sind eben auch menschen dieser
okay ich bin jung ich bin gesund also
warum soll ich mich impfen lassen und
wenn das hauptargument wegfällt und da
stimmen sie mir hoffentlich zu weil das
ja wirklich inzwischen wieder
wissenschaftlich widerlegt ist dass
ungeimpfte pfleger andere gefährden dann
ist ja doch gibt es doch gar keinen
grund warum der staat jetzt sagen soll
weil sie in der pflege arbeiten müssen
sie sich impfen lassen also sie
entscheiden doch dann nur über ihre
eigene gesundheit und nicht darüber ob
sie andere gefährden und nur die
gefährdung anderer wäre für mich ein
plausibles argument bei der masern im
pflicht zum beispiel dass man sagt also
die die geimpft sind wir können
niemanden mehr anstecken das wäre
tatsächlich ein gewichtiger grund zu
sagen dann sollte man das sein lassen
aber das ist nicht so und was sich auch
empörend finde das ist zum beispiel
warum hier kein schutz wirklich nach wie
vor realisiert wird warum wird nicht in
den pflegeheimen und krankenhäusern bis
heute nicht systematisch getestet die
stiftung patientenschutz hat jetzt noch
einmal laut öffnen das eingefordert weil
schon wieder in ein pflegeheim sechs
alte menschen gestorben sind alle
gepostet weil das weil das virus
reingekommen ist testen in diesen
bereichen das wäre wichtig aber nicht
pflegerinnen und pfleger quasi
rauszuschmeißen und nicht weiter ihren
beruf ausüben zuletzt 1 akzeptiere ich
nicht und das ist dass die impfung
dargestellt wird als die fortsetzung der
freiheitsbeschränkungen der von denen
die impfung ist der weg aus den
freiheitsbeschränkungen der pandemie
heraus und das gilt auch im gesundheits-
und natürlich ist es nein die begründung
eine begründung für die einigende war
ihm dass der regen
patienten nicht anstecken kann in dem
moment wo er zwar weniger infektiös ist
aber die patienten doch ansteckt
entfällt dieses argument und da hat frau
wagen nicht völlig recht dass testen
wäre sehr viel effizienter wenn man dann
weiß innerhalb einer schicht kann ein
pfleger der sich früh morgens hat testen
lassen und negativ war zwar auch
infektiös werden aber erst wenn er nicht
geimpft ist es ist sogar noch kurioser
wenn er nicht geimpft ist spürt er
möglicherweise heftigere symptome und
weiß schneller dass er infiziert ist als
wenn er sich in falscher sicherheit
wiegt ist gebucht hat und hat die den
virus auf der schulter so ganz wichtig
das testen in alten- und pflegeheim muss
flächendeckend erfolgen ich bin froh
dass wir das auf den weg gebracht haben
wenn das noch nicht flächendeckend
erfolgt sein muss sofort kommen das
bringt auch viel mehr als eine impfung
bei der wie sie richtig sagen die
ansteckungsgefahren noch gegeben ist
aber sie haben es ja gerade selber
gesagt die leute sind weniger infektion
wenn wir am ende die situation haben
doch das wird es ganz kurz sagen dass
auch pfleger eine situation erleiden in
der sie krank werden hat mende
langzeitschäden von corona davon tragen
dann ist es wichtig auch in diesem
bereich die den pflegenotstand zu
bekämpfen aber richtig hierzu sorgen
wollen dass die leute klauen gehen jetzt
mit großem interesse und mir fällt auf
sehen wir nicht das große
fehlverhalten der politik hier auch
wieder unter brennglas also testen wäre
die beste lösung haben wir doch
eingeführt ja auch in der ich will da
noch sagen aber wir kriegen es nicht
gebacken es wird sozusagen nicht
getestet und deshalb wären andere
menschen gezwungen sich impfen zu lassen
oder sie verlieren den job das ist ja
das ist das eine und ich sehe darin ich
das nicht einhellige so klein ist ein
organ in schleswig holstein sehr wird
auch ein halber hat er genau dass
eingeführt und in alten und pflegeheimen
flächendeckend getestet also da müssen
wir uns noch mal informieren aber ich
halte das für absolut richtig das zu
machen das gegeneinander auszuspielen
zwar werden sie denn das ist der fall
wären sie denn dann dafür wenn man denkt
man hat überall flächendeckend test dass
man dann ungeimpfte pfleger und
krankenschwestern trotzdem die
möglichkeit gibt dazu arbeite ich bin
dafür dass sich alle krankenpfleger und
alle krankenschwestern lassen wenn sie
darauf dass
daraus eine situation ergibt das im
pflegeheim schließen muss oder wie eine
situation haben wo leute nicht mehr
betreut werden können dann muss das in
den ländern gelöst werden als dies
akzeptieren nicht dass ausgerechnet
leute wie herr kretzschmar oder leute
wie herr söder die der ganz die die
ganze zeit der ampel anweisungen geben
wollen jetzt ausgerechnet sagen sie
wollen
rein bringen bevor wir uns wieder in
prien zirkus verlieren ob sie jetzt
markus söder gut fällt oder die anderen
als bürgerin interessiert mich das gar
nicht mehr entfalten mich interessiert
jetzt die einrichtungs beziehung im
pflicht da habe ich eine frage zu
studien legen nahe dass 90 prozent der
pflegekräfte längst geimpft sind warum
also muss man jetzt bis zum letzten alle
zwingen und dann damit lebensträume
zerstören weil wir immer noch
konstellationen haben in denen leute
corona gekommen und dann schwere
langzeit folgen davontragen und dann
nicht mehr im gesundheitssystem arbeiten
können also haben sie auch eine
verschlimmerung des pflegenotstands sie
sich meisten die lieber vorher raus als
da sein und leute eigentlich reichen
kann warum ich nicht voll genau das ist
das was ich ihm vorwerfe sie stellt sie
politisieren diese impfung in einer
weise die an weinen ist ich will doch
einfach nur dass jeder der arbeit leiden
kann nix das sage ich auch ganz bewusst
der dazu beiträgt dass wir endlich auf
diesen freiheitsbeschränkungen rauskommt
ich will keine lockdown maßnahmen ja ich
will keine schulschließung mehr ich will
dass die leute ins theater gehen können
ich will dass die leute wieder ihre
betriebe auf machen also ich meine
beine helfen ja aber bei uns gibt es
doch für all diese maßnahmen überhaupt
keine grundlage mehr aus leder auch im
zwanzigsten mal wieder nicht sagen sie
wollen ja ein pfleger sich impfen lassen
damit es läuft das eine hat mit dem
anderen nichts zu tun ich bin ja auch
durchaus der meinung dass es bei älteren
menschen oder mit bestimmten
vorerkrankungen
das ist sinnvoll und ein schutz ist wenn
sie sich impfen pflegerinnen und pfleger
sind meistens eher nicht so ältere
menschen weil der körperlich harter
beruf und meistens vielleicht auch nicht
mit den unbedingten vorerkrankungen vor
allem sind viele auch wahrscheinlich
gewesen also die haben das hinter sich
diesen besser geschützt als die
geimpften so und jetzt kommt der staat
und sagt also diese berufsgruppe da
gehen wir jetzt hin und sagen ihr müsst
euch impfen verpflichtend sonst haben
der berufsverbot dafür geht es noch 1
auch der mediziner auch studenten die
zehen und also ich meine auch bei
zahnarztpraxen und ähnlichen das ist ja
ziemlich weit es geht ja bis hin zur
cafeteria im krankenhaus und das ohne
die wissenschaftliche grundlage die
rechtfertigen würde zu sagen man schützt
damit jemand sie haben jetzt auch gesagt
nicht mehr schranken soll der wahl
beschließen werden geschichten oder
geben die infektiosität ist vermindert
auch bei omikron also fing ich habe vor
kurzem ein video gesehen von herrn
strikt da hatte das ganz klar
geschildert hat gesagt als zweifach
geimpft das sind gar nicht geschützt bei
der booster impfung ist es so dass es
maximal drei monate die infektiosität
verringert das schon und danach ist es
wieder genauso wie bei ungeimpften das
heißt konsequenterweise müssten sie die
pflegekräfte verpflichten sich alle drei
monate ostern zu lassen und glaube ich
kann das kein ernst zu nehmender mensch
vertreten aber nur dann hätten sie
tatsächlich einen gewissen
infektionsschutz also ich glaube wir
haben wir sind beim dadurch dass wir ist
impfung nennen haben wir einen
qualitätsanspruch an eine impfung die
mental davon ausgeht die krankheit wird
abgeschaltet wie ähnlich wie es bei
anderen impfungen ist das passiert hier
nicht dann hätte sonst hätte ich
verständnis dafür also wenn es eine
gelbfieberimpfung wäre 98% kriege ich
die krankheit nicht würde ich sagen gut
könnten wir darüber reden so sehe ich
das nicht das andere ist wenn sie ein
gesetz beschließen in der ampel und dann
gibt es die ausführungsbestimmungen
nicht wer bitte schön soll denn im
pflegeheim die impf nachweise einsammeln
wer weiß was zu tun ist wenn jemand sagt
zeige ich dir nicht was passiert wenn
derjenige sagt ich kann ja in der
zwischenzeit als hausmeister unten
arbeiten pflege ich halt nicht mehr
darauf der da bleiben darf man nicht da
bleiben wenn er nicht da bleiben darf
kriegt der arbeitslosengeld 1 gerichte
arbeitslosengeld 2 es ist nichts
geregelt und meinen die ampel beschließt
so was das gesundheitsministerium müsste
die ausführungsbestimmungen machen
liefert nicht und dann sollen die länder
irgendwie gucken ja das gesundheitsamt
wird schon irgendwas finden dann fängt
jedes gesundheitsamt in einer region an
der regeln zu machen ist völlig irre
also dann ist so ein herzensanliegen ist
dann bitte aber auch liefern also ein
herzensanliegen ist es ganz bestimmt
nicht aber es ist ein weg der dazu
führen wird hoffentlich dass wir im
nächsten herbst und im nächsten winter
keine so weitreichenden
freiheitsbeschränkung haben wir das
nochmal erleben
kommentierte meinungen wenn du jetzt ein
resultat abgeben musste unserer sehr
lebhaften debatte
die beiden kommen nicht zusammen aber
das ist ja eigentlich
in der demokratie was schön ist ich
glaube dass man noch den fokus weiten
muss und sagen muss erschreckenderweise
haben ja heute stolz unser kanzler hat
gesagt dass er sich mit 16
ministerpräsidenten einig weiß dass die
impfpflicht für alle also die allgemeine
impfpflicht sozusagen auch kommen soll
also das bedeutet diese im fetisch als
der staat legt fest dass sich alle
irgendwie impfen lassen müssen er ist
nicht vom tisch das ist das gegenteil
von freedom day das ist quasi weiter die
anmaßung in die persönliche entscheidung
von menschen massiv einzugreifen aber
ich habe es ehrlich natürlich die hand
eine wissenslücke sie wollen auch das
alles gegeben für das ich nicht würde
mir wünschen dass der sich impfen lassen
ich traue den leuten aber zügig mit den
argumenten auseinanderzusetzen deswegen
soll die sich beraten lassen okay und
dann gucken werden die bereits das war
ja genau die varianten variant und dann
gucken wir mal im september ob wir
wirklich alle im fluss brauchen unter
dem motto wenn du dich nicht beraten
lässt
vielleicht bereits zusammenhang klar
machen inzwischen den zwischen der
abwesenheit von freiheitsbeschränkungen
und der impfung ich habe das gerade
schon gesagt ich will keine neuen
maßnahmen mehr die nummer muss jetzt
auch mal gleich hättest du gehen dürfen
ich verstehe diese verbindung nicht man
muss doch jetzt eher mal recherchieren
ob wir jemals die schulen hätten
schließen dürfen aber ist jeweils
notwendig erschien dann lassen sie uns
das recherchieren das müssen wir machen
aber wir müssen auch verhindern und da
haben wir glaube ich wirklich den
eindruck haben viele leute in
deutschland keinen bock drauf dass wir
im september oktober 20 22 wieder an
derselben stelle stehen wie im letzten
jahr
ich meine mit omikron ist zunächst mal
nicht damit zu rechnen wenn das virus
auf der ebene bleibt wie omikron also
was die krankheit schwerer angeht dann
sehen wir doch jetzt wir haben aktuell
weniger patienten mit corona in den
intensivstationen als wir wahrscheinlich
sonst um diese jahreszeit
grippepatienten in den intensivstationen
hatten und ist sie haben wenn sich das
land in dem ausklappbaren den lockdown
geschickt so jetzt weiß man nicht herr
lauterbach ist ja immer dabei uns ganz
schlimm diese mutanten vorherzusagen
keiner weiß es also natürlich kann das
theoretisch passieren dass das virus
mutiert und auch wieder schwerer
schwerwiegender wird aber was ziemlich
sicher ist wenn es weiter mutiert dann
ist das eben so eine flucht mutter die
omikron das heißt weil sonst kann sich
ja gar nicht so gut verbreiten das heißt
das ist dann eine mutante die sowohl die
genesenen als auch die geimpften wieder
infizieren wird da brauchen wir neue
impfstoffe das ist einfach falsch wenn
sie den leuten weismachen wenn jetzt
ganz viele sich impfen die impfung hat
jetzt für die delta variante geschützt
und bei omikron auch noch so
einigermaßen da ist es schon schwächer
da ist es schon viel schwächer da ist
nur zum glück so dass die omikron
variante nicht gefährlich ist aber es
ist völlig absurd so zu tun dass jetzt
die impfung für den herbst vorbereitet
das wissen wir nicht also erstmal sehen
wir dass die impfung nach einer gewissen
zeit ihren impfschutz auch verliert also
der schutz lässt nach das ist so und das
zweite ist eben wenn dann neue
mutationen kommen dann muss man
vielleicht auch eine neue impfung haben
das heißt die leute jetzt zu
verpflichten heißt noch lange nicht dass
der herbst entspannt wird ich hoffe
allerdings dass die virologen recht
haben die sagen es ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass nochmal schwerere
varianten kommen und dann ist es
tatsächlich so dann haben wir ein neues
zusätzliches atemwegs virus das wird im
winter kursieren es wird wahrscheinlich
auch wieder mehr influencer geben wenn
wir irgendwann maßnahmen aufheben aber
das hatten wir früher auch und das
einzige was wir machen sollten ist unser
gesundheitssystem in einem besseren
zustand zu versetzen indem wir den
pflegenotstand bekämpft das ist ein
super stichwort vorwagen gleich ganz
toll ich wollte und jetzt kommen nämlich
zu claus strunz und zum intensivbetten
weil genau das was frau bank ich gerade
angesprochen hat ist das wobei klar
sturz sprechen wird ja also heute hat ja
sich so ein zitat von karl lauterbach
besser gesagt seines ministeriums in die
öffentliche debatte geschlichen das wie
ich finde
einem skandal gleich kommt oder
zumindest absolut unglaubliches denn auf
eine anfrage an das ministerium
geantwortet die
intensivstationen in deutschland war nie
überlastet was ich dachte dass der grund
für all diese maßnahmen
nein sie waren überlastet weder in den
regionen natürlich ein paar da wurden
100 mehr etwas mehr als 100 patienten
verlegt in ein anderes krankenhaus das
kommt ja wenn man logistik planen kann
mal vor aber diese apokalypse wir müssen
jetzt handeln wir müssen jetzt schulen
schließen wir müssen in den lockt waren
wir müssen ausgangssperren machen weil
in unseren krankenhäusern ereignen sich
furchtbare szenen die intensivstationen
sind überlastet ich höre alle politiker
ist ein fan karl lauterbach da war noch
nicht minister höre ich es sagen das
wird kommen das wird kommen und so oder
dabei geguckt das wird kommen mit dieser
rhetorik hat er sozusagen
begründet grundrechts einschränkungen
größeren ausmaßes zu legitimieren und
die politik ist voll darauf eingestiegen
und jetzt stellt sich heraus das
hauptargument wir sind fallen die
intensivstationen waren überlastet und
wahrscheinlich wenn man genau hinschaut
und das haben wir getan waren sie auch
nur selten oder nie in der nähe
überlastet zu sein und die ziemlich
etwas ganz schönes sagen wenn man
vielleicht die zeit genutzt und die
intensivstation besser auszustatten mit
menschen und material dann wäre dieses
problem doch viel weiter von uns weg
gerückt und was bedeutet das jetzt lasst
uns eine kleine zusammenfassung wir
wissen jetzt masken bringt nicht so viel
wie man gedacht lockt da uns haben
überhaupt nichts gebracht die
intensivstationen waren überlastet aber
wir haben es geschafft und ganze ist ja
ein ganzes land teilweise lahmzulegen
mit deren folgen ökonomische
psychologische gesellschaftliche
meine sorge ist dass ich am ende
herausstellt es war gar nicht corona
schuld an all den folgen sondern
überzogene unangemessene
unverhältnismäßige maßnahmen und wenn
diese hypothese zu treffen dann ist die
schlimmste longo wird folge ein
eklatanter glaubwürdigkeitsverlust der
politik und wenn ich heute genau
zugehört habt wie die zauderer und
hasenfüße die chance vertan haben sofort
alles zu öffnen sondern sich wieder noch
einige schritte und hier noch ein
schritt und wie sie dann sich
austauschen über detail probleme das
alles nimmt mich nicht ein als fan der
föderalismus und der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dabei bin
ich eigentlich großer fan der demokratie
[Musik]
ja also ich muss da wirklich kann da nur
zustimmen und ich war auch etwas
erstaunt überhaupt aussagen über last
aber das interessante ist wir hatten das
im letzten herbst schon mal ein herr
spahn als gesundheitsminister hat einen
wissenschaftlichen beirat extra
eingesetzt sie sollten sich auch an
gefahren denn in der welle davor also da
waren ja die zahlen tatsächlich auch
noch mal höher als jetzt im herbst ohne
impfung immerhin das erste corona jahr
waren da die die intensivstation und die
krankenhäuser jemals überlastet und es
war tatsächlich so ich glaube im letzten
april ist das rausgekommen ganz amtlich
bestätigt haben sie gesagt na ja die
waren nicht überlastet und jetzt
bestätigt lauterbach das auch natürlich
heißt das nicht dass nicht in den
krankenhäusern trotzdem an vielen
stellen ziemlich schlimme zustände waren
aber das ist etwas das haben wir auch
pflegerinnen und pfleger erzählt das
haben wir regelmäßig im winter immer
wieder gehabt und ich habe auch alte
presse mitteilte presse berichte gelesen
da stand dann auch da wurde also
verzweifelt wurden dann intensiv
patienten verlegt in andere bundesländer
das waren alles berichte aus der zeit
vor corona zum beispiel aus dieser
grippewelle 2017 2018 da hatten wir das
massenhaft das intensivstation voll
waren dass menschen verlegt werden
mussten das übrigens auch operationen
verschoben werden mussten das ist nichts
neues und ich sage nicht dass das was
schönes ist also ich finde man sollte
was dagegen tun aber das was man dagegen
tun kann ist nicht das land immer wieder
in den lotter und zu schicken und ich
habe mir auch immer wieder diese zahlen
auch an ruft auch beim diw also da wird
ja immer so diese ganze reihe der chor
der der intensivpatienten
und das erstaunliche ist die hat keine
großen ausschläge also das ist immer
relativ konstant das gleiche und es gibt
so eine analyse dass die krankenhäuser
im jahr 2020 und 2021 übrigens auch im
durchschnitt kann man immer sagen der
durchschnitt ist eben nicht die spitze
aber im durchschnitt deutlich weniger
belegung hatten als in allen jahren
davor also den sommer die gesamtzahl der
patienten ist rückläufig gewesen und da
kann man sagen gut 2020 gab es ja noch
politische auflagen dass sie frei halten
mussten zwar sind jetzt wo es 21 gab es
das aber nicht mehr also warum sinken
eigentlich die belegungen in den
krankenhäusern und gleichzeitig wird
überlastung des gesundheitssystems um
hauptargument passiver grundrechte
einschränkung also das passt einfach
nicht zusammen herr coole darauf waren
sie vermutlich ja ich ärgere mich
darüber warum herr lauterbach so was
sagt und mein stück na ja ich würde das
gerne auf geklärt wer als ich das letzte
mal geschaut habe da sind leute von
einem bundesland ins andere geflogen mit
mit der bundeswehr wir haben patienten
315 glaube ich weine des
inhalts kann als auch darüber dass sie
viel zeit oder habt ihr nun als auch
nicht so interessant zu sehen dass leute
von dem einen oder anderen noch verlegt
große krankenhäuser bei mir im wahlkreis
wo die leute gesagt haben wir haben
große probleme auf der intensivstation
bitte tu was ja bitte setzt euch dafür
ein dass wir corona in den griff kriegen
habe ich immer gesagt na ja es wäre ganz
gut wenn wir eine impfung hätten mit der
wir flächendeckend versorgen können dass
es keine freiheitseinschränkung braucht
und so lange wir nicht genug leute
geimpft haben brauchte es eben leider
auch einschränkungen wo ich der meinung
bin der staat massiv über das ziel
hinaus geschossen ist wir haben
teilweise das parlament entmachtet mit
der epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite gut dass wir das hinter uns
gebracht haben wir haben teilweise auf
ausgangs beschränkungen gesetzt also die
bewegungsfreiheit von leuten
eingeschränkt sich draußen an der
frischen luft nachts einfach sportlich
zu betätigen absurd das hätten wir nicht
machen dürfen das war ein fehler ich bin
jetzt im nachhinein die begründung
geändert wird dann zerstört das
vertrauen und das sollte lauter wird
lässt er wie ist die lage aktuell macht
die politik jetzt gerade alles richtig
ist wurde jetzt gerade gelobt wie jetzt
die wege sind der entscheidung mich
würde vor allem noch mal interessieren
wie hat geguckt
das problem an dieser intensivbetten
zählerei ist dass es ein dynamisches
intensivbetten management gibt wir
hatten anfang dezember etwa 5 1000
intensivbetten im mitte februar hatten
wir 2700 etwa die werden abgebaut von
den krankenhäusern und wieder
aufgestockt das kann man das kann man da
wird selbst ist so wie soll ich sagen so
na ja so ist das aber ja wir hatten 5000
und als dann sozusagen carola richtig
wurden weggefegt das waren es noch 2700
verstehen zwischen der zwischendurch gab
es noch einen viel komplizierteren
mechanismus hat jens spahn für solche
freigehaltenen betten sonderprämien
ausgelobt dann grassierten auf einmal
die intensivbetten weil natürlich die
krankenhäuser wo ist was zu holen gibt
die bettenzahlen aufstocken ist alles
schon ist alles dokumentiert aber die
intensivbetten zahl war eigentlich nie
eine maßzahl das problem an der jetzigen
politik ist glaube ich dass man nicht
weiß wie man von den bauern runterkommt
auf dem man sitzt und bei herrn grube
habe ich manchmal den eindruck er ist
noch ein bisschen in der opposition wir
müssen jetzt langsam wieder ein bisschen
einschwören na ja dann immer noch drei
unterschiedliche parteien in der ampel
regierung und das soll auch erstmals
viel freude im absoluten muss auch
erkennbar bleiben in der koalition
einmal regieren will dann muss man
diesen schritt gehen aber natürlich gibt
es unterschiedliche meinungen seiner
kollektion sind also kein kubicki ich
bin manchmal team kubicki wenn es zum
beispiel darum geht ausgangs
beschränkungen zu verhindern ich bin
aber der meinung wenn wir es nicht
schaffen im nächsten herbst winter eine
ausreichende impfquote zu haben dann
braucht man alternativen kritik würde ja
eindeutig sagen die maßnahmen müssen
jetzt alle weg wenn jetzt die begründung
also ich meine das muss man sich einmal
vorstellen das war nie überlastet dann
sich heute das hier mit einer meinung
das ist echt krass nicht also ich habe
informationen aus dem gesundheitssystem
was normale leute die da arbeiten hier
erzählt und die sagen die situation war
jetzt schlimmer als in der normalen
grippe werden also dass sie ernsthaft
sagen dass cola auf den
intensivstationen genauso wie in der
gruppe das deckt sich überhaupt nicht
mit der antriebswelle auf waren
irgendwann aber ist die überlastung da
war dass die intensivstationen voll
waren dass die pfleger am rande ihrer
kräfte waren dass leute verlegt werden
mussten das hatten wir vor kronen
zeitung habe ich auch mal nachricht auch
schon vor ein paar jahren darauf
hingewiesen das ist schlimm wird für die
aktion da muss halt was nicht das ist
aber corona hat die situation auf der
intensivstation zusätzlich belastet so
habe ich es wahrgenommen die maßnahmen
die dann unternommen worden sind die
muss man aber eng begrenzt und ich habe
das gefühl mitunter sind plötzlich
diejenigen rechtfertigungsbedarf dich ja
die maßnahmen aufheben wollen und
diejenigen die immer was neues
verlängern verlängern wollen die
tauschen sozusagen die gründe dass die
argumente stellt das kann nicht sein
die haben genau aber die haben
angesichts der knappen betten die herr
schuler beschrieben hat ja genau den
ausschlag gegeben dass daum oder verlegt
werden mussten na ja gut aber man hat
eben auch betten abgebaut also man hat
ja allein im letzten jahr über 5000
betten abgebaut wegen des
pflegenotstands also nicht einfach so
aber trotzdem waren die weniger
vorhanden nachdem man vorher mit sehr
viel milliarden öffentlichen geld
zusätzliche betten gesponsert hat die
dann in den kellern standen und wir
haben ja zum beispiel die situation
selbst im herbst in der del tabelle wo
nun sehr viel mehr menschen auch in die
intensivstation mussten als jetzt unter
omikron waren in der spitze 4900
menschen in den intensivstation mit
corona und wenn ich dann sehe dass 5000
betten weniger zur verfügung stehen muss
man ja sagen die korona patienten auch
nur bei gleichbleibenden kapazitäten
wären gar nicht ins gewicht gefallen und
ein staat der sich immer darauf bezieht
dass er die überlastung des
gesundheitswesens verhindern muss der
muss doch verdammt noch mal in die
pflicht genommen werden zumindest etwas
dagegen zu tun dass die belastungsgrenze
immer weiter absinkt also das muss doch
teil seiner aufgabe sein und nicht immer
nur zu sagen wir müssen jetzt die
gesellschaft eine politische forderung
ändert doch nichts an der tatsache dass
krebsoperationen und
vorsorgeuntersuchungen verschoben werden
mussten weil man über corona die
kapazitäten nicht mehr hat oder sein
werden wir mussten eben oftmals gar
nicht verschoben werden weil die
krankenhäuser leer waren wir hatten das
in berlin gleich in der ersten welle
schon dass die auslastung eben nicht so
hoch war und es wurden
bauchspeicheldrüsen op s knie-op es
verschoben die man gut hätte machen
können selbst solche op s wo man am
abend wieder nach hause geht hätten ja
jetzt nicht den operationssaal den
ganzen tag gebunden an einnahmen dann
wurde alles stunden darauf angewiesen
dass mir die leute aus den
krankenhäusern da die wahrheit sagen er
ist wird tatsächlich glauben
bemerkung gemacht dass das ist natürlich
solche krankenhäuser und solche gang
häuser gibt und wir uns immer leicht tun
wenn man immer genau das krankenhaus mit
seinen erzählungen das zu den eigenen
reisepass ist er
deswegen bin ich aber das ist ja jetzt
wird es nichts diese aussage von
lauterbach das ist ja eine offizielle
aussage des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums auf eine
anfrage wenn ich's richtig im kopf von
herrn also das bedeutet das ist das ist
jetzt also wenn man überhaupt dann was
glauben kann dann würden sagen dann
dieses zahlenwerk glaube ich und das
finde ich schon gerüstet aber da sagt
dass er danach hat er sagt
unser segensreiches wirken hat ja dazu
geführt dass ist dass sie nie
ausgelastet waren aus der falle kommt
man nicht raus das werden wir nie
beweisen können ja ich wertschätze
dieses argument auch denke mir dann aber
es kommt ein zweites argument übrigens
immer na ja aber die ganze welt hat ja
quasi locker und so weiter verhängt also
so verrückt war ja deutschland da nicht
aufnehmen auf einem sonderweg aber es
gibt trotzdem den deutschen weg der
wirkt holpriger langsamer schlechter
daten passiert sondern eher so gefühlt
also gefühlte politik statt daten
passiert die politik übrigens keinen
vorwurf weil es gibt keine daten keine
gescheiten die gesundheitsämter fakten
alles mögliche trifft erst viel später
ein als man es braucht das sind andere
länder uns voraus ich finde nur die
konsequenz aus einer solchen aussage des
gesundheitsministeriums muss ja sein
jetzt sofort alle maßnahmen weg jetzt
sofort auch diese verfluchte masken
pflicht weg jetzt sofort rückzug bei
impfpflicht dass ich mir heute anhören
muss ich hab's mir gesagt aber es regt
mich das sagt mir ich hätte am meisten
auf das der scholz sich hinsetzt und ich
weiß möchte mit den 16
ministerpräsidenten einig und jetzt
werden wir dafür eine mehrheit zu
bekommen ich wünsche mir so sehr dass
keine mehrheit im bundestag gibt für die
allgemein so schnell hat das nicht
gesagt
das stimmt hat lancom gesprochen hat er
war heute wieder oder immer muss ich
auch zur pubertät will im einst so gut
halten wer so eine geile performance bei
putin hatte der ist dann wenn er in
diesem kleinen teilchen
gehalten dass das korrespondiert wenn
möglich mit der länge der fische aber
gesetzt die auch in einer stadt wo man
ja landtagswahlen schätzt insofern sind
ist das zahlen corona jetzt auch nicht
verblüffend jetzt machen wir bank hat
unter corona die gemüter sind erhitzt
wir machen weiter mit dem thema was
heute constantin coole beschäftigt ja
ich finde heute ist ein tag zur freude
denn der europäische gerichtshof mit
endlichen dargestellt und klargestellt
dass der rechtsstaat mechanismus scharf
geschaltet werden kann und zwar
gegenüber polen und gegenüber ungarn
beide staaten polen und ungarn sind
freiwillig mitglieder der europäischen
union geworden in beiden staaten gibt es
ganz viele menschen die hoffnungen
verknüpfen mit einer mitgliedschaft in
der europäischen union und wir müssen
feststellen dass die justiz immer weiter
beeinträchtigt wird das richter aus dem
amt entfernt werden in polen dass die
opposition in ihren rechten beschnitten
wird das medium knapp gemacht werden
denn ungarn und wenn so etwas passiert
dann ist das mit den rechten der
europäischen union nicht vereinbaren wer
auf der einen seite so menschenrechte
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie mit
füßen tritt der kann ich auf der anderen
seite dann auch noch gelder aus dem eu
haushalt bekommen deswegen haben viele
gefordert dass an den neuen eu-haushalt
eine rechtsstaats mechanismus geknüpft
werden muss wer so was macht der muss
damit rechnen dass gelder gekürzt werden
ja hat man gesagt ist das denn wirklich
in ordnung dagegen geklagt bis vor den
europäischen gerichtshof der hat heute
gesagt ja es geht das bedeutet großer da
von der leyen muss jetzt handeln kein
geld mehr für eu-recht staatssender
sehe ich komplett anders wenn anfangen
wenn wir anfangen staaten untereinander
wie ein bußgeldbescheid bei einem beim
falschparken zu bestrafen zu wollen dann
sind wir eigentlich da wo wir früher mit
krieg waren in europa wir haben es als
deutsche japaner versucht andere zu
disziplinieren jetzt geht es mit
bußgeldern sollen alle auf einen pfad
getrimmt werden so einfach ist es nicht
wenn wir europa erhalten wollen müssen
wir uns im klaren sein dass wir
unterschiedliche mentalitäten
unterschiedliche herangehensweise
irgendwie akzeptieren sonst können wir
gerne auch noch einen graben nach
osteuropa auf reisen dann haben wir die
nächsten länder die von der fahne gehen
dann ist europa
nicht an dem körperteil was ich jetzt
nicht nennen will so funktioniert es
einfach nicht nationen abzustrafen auch
aus brüssel auch im besten willen und
wissen und gewissen funktioniert nicht
und mit abgesehen davon muss man sich
auch mal ganz
selbstkritisch mal in aller stille
fragen wenn wir über polnische gerichte
her ziehen weil sie angeblich politisch
dominiert werden der
richterwahlausschuss ist
selbstverständlich bei uns völlig
unpolitisch und dass da zwei hochrangige
cdu politiker mit drin sitzen schade
aber die schalten das komplett ab die
essen zwar vorher mit der kanzlerin und
urteilen dann hinterher darüber ob die
kritik an der kanzlerin gerechtfertigt
waren an der korona politik aber das ist
völlig unparteiisch selbstverständlich
ironisieren jetzt sieht man muss nicht
einfach vorstellen wie diese zustände
aus der sicht von warschau aussehen und
man kann wirklich viktor orban alles
mögliche vorwerfen korruption ist zb ein
großes problem im lande aber dass er
kein europäer wäre das kann man nämlich
unterstellen und die grenzsicherung die
wir in belarus gefördert haben und die
wir in griechenland auf der an der
grenze zur türkei auch noch mit
eu-geldern gefördert haben die haben wir
bei viktor orban schwer kritisiert
obwohl auch für uns die migrationsströme
abgebrochen hatte ich frage mich jemand
überhaupt auf die idee kommen kann zu
glauben dass das in irgendeiner weise
deutsche werte wären die wir den polen
oder den ungarn aufzwingen wollten das
sind unsere gemeinsamen europäischen
werte werden den vertrag unterschrieben
bestehende regeln drin und da ist
freiwillig gesagt worden wir wollen
damit machen übrigens aus gutem grund
und das ist auch eine schöne sache weil
europa endet nicht an der oder sondern
geht weiter erholen die polnische nation
ist eine stolze europäische nation
und was ihre schulen eigentlich einige
beim 1 die schweizer
setzten sich dann einfach richter aus
dem amt fegen weil sie damit nicht mehr
einverstanden sind was sie machen
einfach so nicht also ich wenn ich bin
ja auch sehr dafür dass wir der eu
darauf achten dass in allen staaten
rechtsstaatlichkeit und liberalität
gewahrt wird ich habe auch wenig
politische sympathien für orban und auch
nicht für die polnische regierung die
frage ist ja nur wenn man das fass
aufmacht wo es endet also ich erinnere
daran dass amnesty international vor
kurzem italien kritisiert hat wegen
einer völlig unverhältnismäßigen
diskriminierung einer minderheit nämlich
der restriktiven zweig maßnahmen am
arbeitsplatz gegen ungeimpfte also ich
meine investiert denn es ist nun schon
der größe wo ich sage wenn die ein land
kritisiert da muss da schon was im argen
sein und wir haben ja vorhin will jetzt
das fass nicht noch mal aufmachen aber
auch über relativ willkürliche
grundrechte einschränkung bei uns
gesprochen oder auch zum beispiel eine
debatte die in deutschland geführt wird
immer stärker jetzt irgendwie so eine
art neuen radikalenerlass also
überprüfung beim verfassungsschutz für
bewerber im öffentlichen dienst wo die
frage auch ist ist das denn dann
wirklich also was eure mittel wieder
geachtet weil ich nicht ich weiß nicht
ich sage doch nicht dass wir jetzt in
deutschland aktuell auf dem level von
polen sind aber ich finde schon also
wenn muss man bei allen die gleichen
maßstäbe anlegen und eigentlich finde
ich sollte die eu eher so eine art
zusammenschluss souveräner staaten sein
wo man schon auch davon ausgeht dass die
unterschiedlich ihre inneren
angelegenheiten
richten weil sonst muss man tatsächlich
bei allen ländern dann mit gleichem
maßstab messen und ich weiß nicht ob das
wirklich diejenige ist die da sie auch
sagen als letzte instanz in frage kommt
das so entstand man muss bei allen
staaten mit dem gleichen maßstäben
messen man muss sich auch mit der frage
beschäftigen ob in deutschland alles so
in ordnung ist ob die wahl von richtern
in deutschland wirklich der weisheit
letzter schluss ist weiß ich gar nicht
diskutieren wir das ändern wir es machen
was mehr demokratisch aber wir müssen
doch in eine bestimmte richtung uns
entwickeln und wir haben uns auf
bestimmte standards in der europäischen
union verständigt und wenn gesagt wird
also die richterliche unabhängigkeit die
passt der regierenden partei nicht
deswegen kicken wir die richter aus dem
amt dann ist das eine ganz gefährliche
typ 2 der wanderer sollen wir noch gar
nicht und ich will nur sagen weil ich
auch wert schätze das natürlich ein
viktor orban auch eine mehrheit in der
ungarischen bevölkerung für sich
gewonnen hat und auch die polnische
regierung ja wahlen gewonnen hat das
heißt wir können nicht einfach sagen wir
machen jetzt mal scharfe maßnahmen gegen
euch und dann werdet ihr hoffentlich
abgewählt sondern wir müssen schon auf
die polnische und die ungarische
bevölkerung vertrauen dass die eine
entscheidung treffen die sie selber
richtig finden denn das ist auch
demokratie aber eines nicht dazu sagen
sagt gernot geng christdemokrat ich bin
dafür muss dafür mussten aus der
minderheit auch noch überhaupt eine
mehrheit werden können das ist der kern
von demokratie dass man überhaupt eine
wahl gewinnen kann und wenn die
verfassung beliebig angepasst wird wenn
medienhäuser beliebig dichtgemacht
werden dann kann irgendwann aus der
minderheit keine mehrheit mehr werden
und deswegen muss man da eingreifen und
kann sich das nicht bieten lassen und
das sind gemeinsame europäische werte
was sagt die europäische union nie
funktioniert wenn wir anfangen plötzlich
bereits regeln zu machen für menschen
die in anderen pass haben denn wir
plötzlich güter nicht mehr exportieren
dürfen andere länder dann werden wir von
der eu auch besteht also ich bin leider
ist einfach miteinander zusammenhängt
und deswegen kein deutsches steuergeld
mehr was nach brüssel überwiesen wird um
dann ein rechtsstaat sünder bezahlt wird
das kann man doch nicht einfach gut
mir gefällt diese passion mir gefällt
dieser bleibens ja kannst du diese er
diese leidenschaft ich bin nah bei ihnen
machen machen machen wir aber sorgen
über die ausgestaltung und wirklich fast
angst vor einem system der gegenseitigen
schuldzuweisungen denn natürlich wenn
das so kommt stellt sich orban hin und
sagt liebe ungarn haben jetzt weniger
geld von der eu und das haben diese
leute in brüssel beschlossen und jetzt
zeige ich euch mal was in deren ländern
los ist und dann macht er die top ten
liste aller da kommen wir auch vor mit
grundrechts einschränkungen keine ahnung
was oder richter bestand
klassischen europäischen ländern und
dann geht s wechselweise dann kommt der
rück- und dann haut sich quasi entlang
dieser eigentlich richtigen gedanken die
eu jede woche ein neues ding um die
ohren und jetzt kann man sagen dass es
dann der streit der zu einer
konstruktiven lösung wird ich habe so
ein bisschen zeige das dass er zu noch
mehr abkehr und noch mehr separatismus
sozusagen in der in der union führt
gedanklich oder oder vom vom impetus her
bin ich bei ihnen dass man natürlich
jemanden der rechtsstaatliche prinzipien
offen verletzt nicht auch noch das geld
in der meist gut aber der deal ist wir
zahlen alle in die kasse in brüssel ein
und dafür wird dann nach einem festen
schlüssel zum beispiel agrarförderung
verteilt jetzt kommt man aber an sagt ja
agrarförderung gut und schön aber
mir passt hier richtig die schließung
dieser zeitung nicht die nur verkauft
wurde an einen anderen kann man sagen je
schräger die alles gut und schön bleiben
wir doch im gespräch machen wir doch
erst mal geltend dass wir zusammen ein
großes europa sein wollen wir sagen
sonntags immer europa muss
zusammenbleiben um mehr gewicht zu
entfalten prima aber dann müssen wir
irgendwie im gespräch bleiben und können
sollten nicht versuchen uns gegenseitig
zu bestrafen und in osteuropa wird
dieses gebaren in brüssel als eine
herablassung als als eine bevormundung
lässt die kanzlerin mehrere millionen
menschen in die europäische union
einreisen ihre koalition übrigens jetzt
jetzt massive migrations anreize die
dann aber alle europäischen länder
betreffen weil es entweder durch
reiseländer werden oder man sich im
schengen raum frei bewegen kann da fragt
niemand in ungarn vorher nach ob denn
der spurwechsel in deutschland ob der
genehm ist und dass man künftig dann
vielleicht auch migranten aus marokko
bis nach budapest ziehen wir können das
ganze ja mal in einer ungarischen
universität in budapest zum beispiel
diskutieren das problem ist dass viktor
orban aber aktiv universitäten also orte
der debatten und der diskussion aus dem
land wirft also wenn ich mal eine
aufregung über cancel culture hören will
dann mal von viktor orban wo leute aus
dem land geschmissen werden ich habe
eine freie lehre wird ich habe mich im
neuen warenkorb das kolleg frei
austauschen können ja das glaube ich
sofort also auch ist ja auch ein
wunderschönes land und wunderbaren nette
menschen mit denen man sich gut
unterhalten kann trotzdem kann man keine
universität aus dem land schmeißen das
ist doch
zurück mit zwei noch sehr spannenden
themen bis gleich
also da kann ich einen lauten und nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
sie bekommen meine damen und herren zum
nachteil der schlagend sein machen mein
name ist wieder fit
so nicht über chat buschi hätten das
auto aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darm führen hoch trafen
die debatten über die rettung des
weltklimas und um die füße russland die
ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig um
es nur der afg zu überlassen lasst den
leuten den spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten ihren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu führen
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
das vorliegen eines heute zum manko
vielleicht einmal
dennoch ist übliche an dem radträger aus
ich hatte meinen beifall um eine sache
immer bekommt er kümmert sich darum
niemand gibt ist
man muss ja ganz kleinen auch darüber
sprechen ganz allein sagt nicht der hat
mich richtig ist die komödie nicht
begraben nur noch vier wochen
[Musik]
während zurück ich werde mich heute mal
nicht über die korona maßregelung der
regierung aufregen dass haben frau
wagenknecht und netterweise schon
erledigt da wir schalten wir jetzt mal
in die ukraine wo mein kollege der vize
bild chef paul ronzheimer ist er hat
wollte schon den ganzen tag dem
ukrainischen präsidenten verbracht ich
würde gerne jetzt mit ihnen darüber
sprechen wie seine eindrücke vor ort
sind paul schön ist uns zu gescheitert
ist wir sind denn deine eindrücke vor
ort du bist in der ukraine wie hoch ist
die kriegsgefahr noch
fühlt sich tatsächlich immer in einer
anderen welt wenn man nicht in
deutschland ist denn hier in der ukraine
spielt natürlich bewohner überhaupt
keine rolle insbesondere dann wenn man
wie ich gerade in der ost ukraine sitze
mario pohl ich sitze in dem hotel von
präsident alan stil der auch hier
übernachtet er schon ins bett gegangen
aber ich war den ganzen tag mit ihm
unterwegs heute im land wir sind mit dem
helikopter quer durchs land geflogen
kann man sagen und das gefühl hier im
land ist so dass man gar nicht verstehen
kann wie erst die panik im westen riesig
war dass ihr krieg ausbrechen könnte man
jetzt sagt naja die russen ziehen jahr
zurück siemens gibt hat zu mir
persönlich gesagt er hat keine belege
dafür dass russische truppen momentan
nicht mehr in der lage sind das land
anzugreifen ganz im gegenteil es gibt
auch ein paar indikationen dass es mehr
drucken gibt als vorher also für mich
sieht es danach aus als hätte sich olaf
scholz dort etwas vom pferd erzählen
lassen von wladimir putin in dieser
woche als er im kreml war
podolski hat zu mir gesagt der
ukrainische präsident als wir dort auf
einem truppenübungsplatz waren auf meine
frage hin wie war es denn wir haben sie
olaf scholz zusammen mit wladimir putin
erlebt er zu mir gesagt ich kann es
nicht sagen ich habe keine nachricht
darüber wie das treffen gelaufen ist
auch das zeigt für mich der westen will
einfach nur ruhe auf kosten der ukraine
und eigentlich ist es deutschland und
der welt egal wie es hier der ukraine
den menschen geht
bei vielen vielen dank für deine
stellungnahme aus der ukraine
wir werden jetzt mal hier am tisch
debattieren wie es aussehen wird wie der
konflikt weiter geht du bist natürlich
noch viel mehr vor ort wir wünschen dir
noch in der halle gut durch in der
ukraine
also ich glaube dass das paul was ganz
entscheidendes benannt hat es mich
gestern die ganze zeit als sich dieses
schauspiel davon stolz bei putin mir
angeguckt habe läuft es so als parallel
film bei mir auch durch den kopf dass
das natürlich von anfang an eine große
inszenierung ist deren
ablaufplan wie in seinem theater
libretto vorgegeben ist und zwar schon
seit januar also es war klar dann kommen
die deutschen die deutschen kriegen die
möglichkeit sich hier sozusagen friedens
bringen einzubringen aber was die
mutigen da den ganzen tag auf seinem
zettel geschrieben hat die er dann
irgendwie nicht mehr lesen konnte
zwischendrin das war ganz sicher nicht
auch hier zwar olaf scholz da jetzt hole
ich meine panzer zurück also das was
paul da spürt in der ukraine ist glaube
ich die eigentliche nachricht aus dem
treffen was passiert da jetzt wirklich
und das ist möglicherweise anders als
das was der obergasse dem kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland glauben
machen wollte und das ist halt schon
beängstigend denn die gesamte presse
meiner meinung nach wirklich alles was
jemals geschrieben hat es gesehen aber
ich habe viel gesehen und da muss man
sagen da gehen die meisten kollegen der
show auf den leim also die sagen ja das
war so ein großer
wir haben bild das etwas kritischer
aufbereitet weil wir paul vor ort haben
und weil wir die andere die andere weise
haben aber mich beängstigt ist schon wie
man mit ein bisschen blümchen auf den
tisch und war wohl gesetzten worten
grimmig dreinschauen und dann mal kurz
schmunzelnd ein eindruck erzeugt als sei
jetzt alles paletti also ich hab ja mit
merkel über viele jahre auch diese
russland diplomatie verfolgt wir haben
wir haben in brisbane beim g-20-gipfel
vom hotel gelegen als vier stunden die
nacht durch verhandelt haben und
russische panzerkreuzer vor der
australischen küste aufgefahren sind
auch mal so ein ganz kleines nettes
symbol bei einem g20 gipfel aber putin
ist ein taktiker es ist völlig abwegig
und deshalb war ich auch war mir klar
das ist ein zu so einer invasion einer
kleinen des klassischen panzer
vorrückens so führt kein mensch mehr
krieg das ist auch unsinn einen
stellungskrieg hat man im letzten
jahrhundert geführt wurde automatisch zu
schwer beschuss aus dem westen führen es
gibt panzerbrechende waffen auch auf
seiten der ukraine ist ist unsinn was er
machen will ist druck erzeugen er hat
dem holz eine gute performance geboten
und so ein bisschen allgemein ich ziehe
auch ein paar leute waren keine zahlen
drin war kein zeitpunkt drin er hat
nichts zurück gezogen ist auch wurscht
scholz hat dort einen schönen auftritt
hingelegt und
ist jetzt freuen sich jetzt putin sehr
viel lieber weil er kennt ja auch die
russland geneigt hat der spd ihm da
geholfen zu haben
ansonsten materiell geändert hat sich
das nicht und es ist eine druck position
jederzeit kann eine ost ukraine irgend
eine provokation inszeniert werden von
welcher seite auch immer und daran kann
sich etwas entzünden das wird auch
künftig so bleiben was putin will ist
mit dem westen im gespräch kommen und er
will natürlich sein vorhof irgendwie
bewahren dass so ziemlich das einzige
was der westen ihm zumindest offen nicht
zugestehen kann das würde ja wie ein
kniefall aussehen das hat bleibt die
situation so verfahren wie sie vorher
war also da würde ich schon wieder
sprechen also ich würde meine rund
einschätzung würde ich das durchaus
teilen also putin und russland hat
überhaupt kein interesse daran jetzt
wird einzumarschieren ich meine diese
don was republiken versuchen jetzt sei
2014 anerkannt zu werden durch russland
russland hat sie nicht anerkannt also
das ist ja ein ganz klarer akt also ich
meine ehemann einmarschiert können wenn
man sie einfach nur anerkennen macht man
nicht macht man aus guten gründen nicht
und es gab ja auch das minsker abkommen
und ich finde man muss jetzt darauf
beharren dass das umgesetzt wird das
minister abkommen sagt die ukraine
selbstverständlich die grenzen sind
unverletzbar aber diese region hat einen
sonderstatus das heißt keine russischen
waffen dahin aber auch keine
ukrainischen drohnen und die haben sich
ja nun mal vor kurzem ersten bewaffnen
lassen mit drohnen und haben sie auch im
donbass eingesetzt so und ich glaube
tatsächlich ja das war jetzt auch eine
deutliche ansage bis hierhin und nicht
weiter von russland bei eines wollen sie
auf gar keinen fall und ich finde dass
der westen gut daran täten das ernst zu
nehmen sie wollen natürlich auf keinen
fall dass die ukraine teil der nato wird
weil die nato sowieso schon über all die
jahre immer näher an russland ran
gerückt ist also heute ist es ja schon
so dass ab iranische truppen stehen 150
km vor sankt petersburg und diese
raketenbasen in polen und in rumänien
wenn man deine raketen abschießt nach
russland da ist jede minuten es sehen
häufig stehen dann natürlich nicht um
moskau oder
die ukraine ist noch mal dichter dran
und ich meine man sollte sich mal das
umgekehrte szenario vorstellen also
mexiko oder venezuela würden eine
militärbündnis beitreten das von china
oder russland angeführt wird und china
oder russland würden in diesen ländern
raketenbasen errichten und würden da
truppen stationieren also ich würde jede
wette eingehen eine regierung in
mittelamerika die so eine entscheidung
treffen würde die wäre keine 24 stunden
mehr im amt weil die amerikaner
reagieren würden und die haben schon für
kleinere zwecke putsche inszeniert also
natürlich würde man sich das auch nicht
bieten lassen und kann man sagen das ist
alles nicht gerechtfertigt freie
entscheidung aber es gibt eben nicht nur
diese die sicherheitsbedürfnisse der
ukraine oder osteuropas die wir ernst
nehmen müssen ich finde auch nicht dass
es richtig ist zu sagen das ist uns egal
das darf uns nicht egal sein aber es
gibt auch sicherheitsbedürfnisse
russlands und russland ist ein land das
vom westen immerhin in seiner geschichte
immer mal wieder überfallen wurde und
zwar mit furchtbaren kriegen und wenn
man sich diese geschichte ansieht da
muss man auch sagen es ist doch legitim
dass ein land sagt wir wollen nicht dass
immer mehr truppen an unseren grenzen
stationiert werden dass immer mehr
raketenbasen dort stationiert werden und
wir als europäer gerade wir als deutsche
glaube ich haben ein wirklich
elementares interesse daran dass wir
gute beziehungen zu russland haben und
das ist der letzte punkt den ich schon
findet den man da auch immer wieder
berücksichtigen muss erkennbar gibt es
wirtschaftliche interessen hinter diesen
konflikt weil wenn das russische gas
mehr und mehr aus europa verdrängt wird
wenn du in ostrau zum beispiel nicht in
betrieb genommen wird dann kommen die
amerikaner mit ihrem fracking gas sehr
gut ins geschäft und zwar viel besser
als sie das sonst schaffen und ich fand
interessant dass der truppenabzug sofort
eine reaktion ausgelöst hat er sie
aktien insgesamt sind gestiegen aber die
aktien der amerikanischen fracking
gashersteller sind richtig auf dich
sinkflug gegangen da muss ich mir doch
hausrechts oder zwei dinge an lassen
dahinter steht aber kann die situation
jetzt akut in der ukraine besser
bewerten als wir hier am tisch aber
eines stört mich an dem doch sehr das
ist diese ganze darstellung dass ein
einmarsch russlands in der ukraine noch
nicht stattgefunden hätte der hat längst
stattgefunden auf der krim und in
provinzen in der ost ukraine da sind
tausende junger europäer gestorben auf
den schlachtfeldern die es da gegeben
hat weil russland einmarschiert ist das
hat stattgefunden hat also wir tun immer
so wir tun immer so als wäre das eine
abstrakte situation das ist eine
handfeste bedrohung die ganz viele
ukrainische familie jeden tag schon
erlebt haben und wir haben ja vorhin
auch über die mentalität und die
einstellung und die öffentliche meinung
in osteuropa gesprochen was ist denn die
öffentliche meinung in estland in
lettland in litauen in polen wie wird
das denn da wahrgenommen wir sprechen
über seinen rücken wie man sich die
truppenbewegungen in belarus anschaut
die ukraine ist komplett umstellt und
umzingelt also diese situation so
einseitig darzustellen das passt mir
nicht ich glaube wir müssen anerkennen
dass hier viele menschen gestorben sind
ich würde auch noch mal daran erinnern
dass ein flugzeug abgeschossen worden
ist auf dem weg von den niederlanden
nach asien wo auch viele menschen
gestorben sind also sicherheitsproblem
für europa ausgelöst durch russland und
diese situation ist nicht aufgelöst man
nach wie vor sehr gefährlich würde mir
oft sehr seine zeit wünschen aber sonst
kommt ein thema gar nicht mehr dran sei
und dementsprechend müssen wir jetzt
rüber gehen die sind etwas harter
schnitt von der ukraine
und ist mit acht bekannten weil die
harten schnitte hier ja ich habe mich
sehr gefreut diese woche dass die das
familienministerium ministerium für
frauen familie und integration heißt das
genau von katharina binz in rheinland
pfalz einen kleinen wettbewerb
ausgeschrieben hat ich muss ich gucken
gerne auf zettel aber ich muss es
ablesen damit ich niemanden aus lasse
die initiative richtet sich an alle
lesbischen schwulen bisexuellen
transienten hinter geschlechtlichen und
nicht die lehrerinnen nicht binären
winzerinnen und winzer aus rheinland
pfalz und die können jetzt noch bis zum
ende februar ihren beiden einreichen und
als klein werden wir damit bewertet ein
abnehmer gibt es auch schon das
ministerium wir 500 flaschen kaufen
dürfen nicht mehr als zehn euro kosten
und dann hinterher repräsentations
geschenke und das volk bringen das feine
sache ich weiß nicht genau
die traube wie die sich beim keltern
anders verhält wenn es unterschiedliche
sexuelle orientierung gibt ich weiß auch
nicht was der weinkenner davon hat wenn
der winzer irgendeiner anderen neigung
dazu gehört als er selbst keine ahnung
im klartext es ist ein wettbewerb für
winzer die sich auch jetzt schon an
allen wettbewerben beteiligen können
aber einen speziellen wettbewerb
bekommen für ihre sexuelle orientierung
außer heteros die dürfen natürlich nicht
machen das ist klar was will man damit
erreichen was was soll das es ist so ein
bisschen hereinspaziert hereinspaziert
jahrmarkt der identitäten
jetzt stellen wir einfach mal leute die
deren handwerk nichts mit ihrer
sexuellen identität zu tun hat den
bieten wir auch mal eine bühne was soll
das ich kann es mir nicht erklären
es hat sich übrigens noch keiner
gemeldet das ist gehört mit dazu hälfte
der ausschreibungs hat sich noch keiner
gemeldet aber
regnen kann ich denke mir ist doch nett
das ist ja deren eigener wettbewerb das
stört mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr aber
naja ich habe immer so ein bisschen den
verdacht dass hinter dieser wagnis
bewegung schon auch beinharte aktivisten
stehen und wenn man da mal genauer an
die papiere reim ließen in die webseiten
dann merkt man schon dass da die
überwindung des hetero normativen
weltbild das dahinter steht und da sage
ich mir einfach leute
nirgends auf der welt kann man so frei
alles ausleben was man so in sich hat
wie hier solange es keine anderen
betrifft aber
warum will man das mehrheits konstrukt
der klassischen familie jetzt in einem
licht stellen als er jetzt nur eines
unter vielen was was soll dass diese
gesellschaft lebt von den familien dann
steht im grundgesetz besonderer schutz
von ehe und familie die leisten bei der
kindererziehung am anfang des lebens
brachial
gute leistungen die man nicht staatlich
ersetzen kann sie leisten am ende des
lebens enorm viel bei der pflege und
daneben gibt es tausende spielarten von
wegen zum glück die alle akzeptiert sind
bei uns was soll solche demonstrativer
akt und als wäre da irgend etwas
aufzuholen also ich würden trinken
[Gelächter]
aber er schmeckt ist doch gut also ich
finde es gar nicht schlimm ich glaube
auch nicht dass die familien in
deutschland zugrunde gehen wenn winzer
im rheinland pfalz dafür ausgezeichnet
werden das den guten wein machen ich
finde die sexuelle identität sollte bei
der weinherstellung auch keine rolle
spielen aber vielleicht probieren sie
ihn auch mal der weiß was es bei ihnen
aus fink ein weintrinker ich würde die
man quer bier trinken
bier es ist nicht so schlecht das ist
natürlich schon ich meine die wir haben
deutlich sträflich vernachlässigt
ischler es gibt zu wenige davon
wenn frau wagenknecht zu einer art mit
herausgeberschaft
eingeschränkt auf bestimmte und es mache
ich
habe an den kohle wird's machen wir
können das auch hier zusammen ich
fürchte ich möchte wusste dass man dass
man der klientel einen bärendienst
erweist indem man sich ins schaufenster
stellt anstatt sie einfach als normale
menschen zu behandeln die sich an
wettbewerben beteiligen ja ich meine im
grunde war ja und das ist ja wirklich
eine errungenschaft der kampf über viele
viele jahrzehnte war ja einfach dass es
keine rolle mehr spielt ob jemand jede
sexuell homosexuell oder was auch immer
ist und ich finde eigentlich also wenn
man es jetzt mal ernsthaft noch mal
betrachtet das ist ja das ziel das
musste erreicht werden und das ist
großartig und
ich meine passt so was nicht dazu dass
es dann plötzlich mit umgekehrten
vorzeichen wieder eine ganz besondere
rolle spielt und ich glaube auch als
schadet tatsächlich weil es leute er ja
ich meine wir haben ja mehr darüber
gelacht das ist eigentlich auch eher
lustig aber manche leute wenn sie so oft
erleben dass sie dann doch irgendwie er
wieder vorbehalte entwickeln und das ist
nicht sinnvoll als großer anhänger von
markt und wettbewerb finde ich der
wettbewerber zu richten und dass ich
noch keine beteiligten sagt es
möglicherweise auch aus über die
sinnhaftigkeit des ganzen unternehmens
das ist doch ein schönes schlusswort
ihnen zu hause noch einen schönen abend
danke dass ihr zugeschaut haben und
morgen abend geht es dann weiter und 2
215 abend noch bis morgen
[Musik]